[Music]
ah college students at Binghamton
University heard Garret reporting on
this in New York shutting down a speech
by conservative economist art Laffer
who's been awarded a Presidential Medal
of Freedom earlier this year so let's
turn in to the editor-in-chief of The
Daily wire Ben Shapiro for more RI Ben
welcome thanks for having me okay so
you've been in these situations where
people don't want you to come you show
up they cause problems what do you make
of this I mean it's free speech on
campus legitimately under attack or is
that basically fear-mongering to cover
these incidents that way I mean there's
a serious problem in particular this is
true at this particular campus it really
does come down to the administration not
the students in other words protesters
very often will get away with what they
think they can get away with they have
held a couple of big speeches in venues
over the last couple of weeks and the
authorities have done a much better job
the administration has done a much
better job of ensuring that if somebody
really disrupts the event there's enough
security there to make sure the person
is removed that everybody else can
continue on with the event at this
particular event is pretty obvious that
the the administration decided to let
the protesters have their way and that
really is the big question
does the administration decide to kowtow
to the hecklers or does the
administration stand up for free speech
and provide enough resources to prevent
these these events from being shut down
so we know two people apparently were
arrested and the administration is
really pushing back on this thing we're
looking into it we want to know who did
what and if they violated policies
they're going to get in trouble the
college fix calm describes the situation
this way they say various videos of the
incident show dozens of students yelling
and disrupting this the lecture with one
man with a microphone declaring quote we
are tired of being oppressed and we are
tired of getting murdered by this
administration referring to the Trump
administration but I don't know what his
exact grievances are but it's clear that
they don't want to hear from anyone they
think is linked to this administration
or anything conservative in nature I
mean these people obviously hate
marginal tax cuts I mean the Laffer
curve I wasn't aware that that art
Laffer was the most controversial member
of sort of the Trump coterie but
apparently if you really really hate
differentials and marginal tax rates
then then our laugher is your man if you
really believe that you're being
murdered because art Laffer proposed
basic notions that if you lower taxes
that you will increase government
revenue
I don't tell you you may need to see
your shrink they don't feel they're not
feeling the Laffer curve okay I want to
take you to another controversy which is
this whole idea that chick-fil-a is
changing the group's that it donates to
out or the Fellowship of Christian
Athletes and the Salvation Army which by
the way has been taking a beating lately
in the mainstream media this is what the
president of chick-fil-a now says in
chief operating officers is beginning in
2020 the chick-fil-a foundation will
introduce a more focused giving approach
donating to a smaller number of
organizations working exclusively in the
areas of hunger homelessness and
education no organization will be
excluded from future consideration
faith-based or non faith-based they're
trying to tamp down which listen on
social media has been a like no more
Nuggets kind of reaction from people
that are conservative it's completely
idiotic completely idiotic but
chick-fil-a's their gross revenue went
from 1 billion dollars in 2001 to ten
point five billion dollars this year and
did so despite the fact that the left
has been targeting them since 2013 when
they found out that Dan Cathy who is the
CEO of chick-fil-a was in favor of
traditional marriage that has not slowed
chick-fil-a's growth one iota and the
fact that chick-fil-a decided to bow
down before the Lords of political
correctness and then cut Christian
charities out because those Christian
charities happened not to support
same-sex marriage militantly is is
pretty astonishing and it's a horrible
sign for our culture I mean if we are
really only going to now eat at
restaurants where the the activities of
the restaurants don't matter at
chick-fil-a we'll serve anybody gay
straight doesn't matter everybody is
happy to eat a chicken sandwich
chick-fil-a will serve that the real
question is if you are going to start
boycotting businesses based on the
personal views of the owners of the
business well then we're gonna end up
with basically a two-tiered political
system in every aspect of American life
and the country can't last that way I
mean if I literally have to check out
the political donation record of the
restaurant owner where I go to patronize
the burger I don't know how we're going
to last as a country this way yeah you
have to feel like the pendulum will
swing back at some point now drew
Anderson who is the director of
campaigns for GLAAD LGBTQ rights
organization says this in addition to
refraining from financially supporting
anti LGBTQ organizations chick-fil-a
still lacks policies to ensure safe
workplaces for LGBTQ employees and
should unequivocally speak out against
the anti LGBTQ reputation that there
Rand represents so the left doesn't
sound satisfied by this move that took
place May because the left will never be
satisfied the Boy Scouts did the same
thing in the left went after the Boy
Scouts once you give an inch to the left
with regard to your fundamental
principles the Left will never stop if
chick-fil-a believes that they bought
off the left through all of this and the
left is suddenly going to start
switching their dollars over from
whatever vegan restaurants they're
patronizing to check the like they've
got another thing coming chick-fil-a is
not going to win any supporters on the
left and they're gonna lose a lot of
supporters on the right who feel like
they surrendered to too nasty censorious
canceled culture you know I think that
gets people more heated is arguing over
which sauce is the best don't at me on
Twitter Ben Shapiro will always great to
have you thank you so much good to see
you